let's use the nail to diagnose some
nutritional deficiencies the outside of
the body gives you a lot of clues on
what's going on inside just as a plant
if there's any type of problems in the
plant can tell you what's going on in
the soil
all right the first presentation is
where you have this vertical
discoloration in the center of your nail
that could be a little protein
that can be low vitamin d
or b12 now you're going to be deficient
in b12 if you have low protein because
b12 usually comes from animal protein
all right next presentation you have
horizontal
lines
that go across that can be low vitamin
b3
low calcium or low
zinc now the next presentation has to do
with that little white speck
in your nail
that is a zinc deficiency mostly caused
because the person is on a high carb
diet and because it takes six months for
the nail to grow you can sort of
identify a time when you had a lot of
carbohydrate because if it's right in
the center it could have been three
months ago all right the next
presentation is where you have this
little chip on your nail now that could
also cross over if you have brittle
nails but if you get these little chips
that just you bang your nail and then
you have this little chip that pops off
that could be low vitamin b6 or low
magnesium but it can also be in this
next presentation where we're talking
about brittle nail low iron or low
hydrochloric acid now if you're low in
hydrochloric acid you're not going to be
able to absorb magnesium or iron too
well so you just might need to add more
acid to be able to absorb these
minerals now if the nail is all white it
could be that you're just very protein
deficient
or your kidney or your liver is damaged
or you took this antibiotic
that could be causing this presentation
if the nail is really really soft okay
it's not very strong that can be low
calcium calcium gives the strength of
the nail makes it very rigid and you may
need vitamin d to help you absorb that
calcium because vitamin d helps the
absorption of calcium by 20 times
in this next presentation we have a club
now kind of a box like
square
and that is usually a heart problem or
it could be a liver problem or a lung
issue because you don't have enough
oxygen all right next presentation is
the spoon effect if the nail starts
coming up like that that is an iron
deficiency so as you can see certain
minerals or certain vitamins
can create different effects on the nail
now if your nail is a bit bluish
that can be low oxygen if your nail is a
bit too yellow
that can be jaundice which is a liver
problem that occurs when there's
obstruction in your bile ducts so it can
also be related to your gall bladder in
which case you need bile salts in this
next presentation we have the lower part
of the nail which is either discolored
or you lost that little
luna that little horizontal white
presentation at the bottom of your nail
that is usually liver cirrhosis it could
be a heart problem or
diabetes now if your nail is becoming
distorted
or it's excessively thick or you have
these horizontal ridges in the center
part
that is usually low biotin which is a b
vitamin in this next presentation you
have these vertical
red lines these are broken capillaries
this is low vitamin c if you have this
condition you may also have bleeding
gums you can have little spider veins
in various parts of your body in this
last presentation we have these vertical
ridges this could be quite a few things
it could be low protein
a high carb diet
could be low b12 or low iron because
you're not getting enough protein
because most b12 and iron comes from
animal protein all right thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
video
hey before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my
content i would love to hear about your
success story please share it in the
link down below